(intense music)
- [Competitor] Nailed it.
(laughing)
- [Nicole] I don't mean to laugh
but your princess is terrifying.
She is so scary looking
and I don't think anybody's
coming to rescue her.
Oh no, and then your
dragon got decapitated.
- [Competitor] Yes.
(sorrowful music)
- But I love this cake so much.
- The princess is a little
bit scary, the eyes!
(alarming music)
- [Jacques] Those big
eyes, she just woke up.
- What voice do you
think your princess has?
- Hi guys.
You need to kill that dragon.
Off with his head.
- So her voice matches her face.
If you stare in her eyes, you'll get-
- Nope, no, thank you, I won't do it.
- [Competitor] Nailed it!
(laughing)
- [Nicole] That looks
like some strange fish
from the bottom of the deep, deep ocean.
- It's like snake fish.
- [Nicole] I love those teeth.
- But, you were really innovative,
and you covered it and moved on.
That's exactly what I would do.
- Nailed it!
- How is that possible?
- Oh no, he's got a happy face there.
- It's not a happy face, it's a--
(emoji boings)
- Just be happy I knew
it was a happy face.
May I ask, what had
happened to your fondant?
- Okay so, Toy was kind
enough to give me her fondant
so with five seconds left I just
threw that fondant on there.
But, I'm almost positive
my art teacher license
is gonna get revoked after this.
- I'm pretty blown away
but fascinated as well,
and the arms are really weirding me out.
- You understand that
the arms are longer than
the legs?
- Oh yeah, yeah!
(drum roll)
- [Competitor] Nailed it.
- [Nicole] I don't mean to laugh,
but what is happening?
Ooh girl it is leaning.
- Well I overfilled my cakes
and it took way too long for them to bake.
And then, they were too hot
and I didn't have enough time
to really cool them down
before I started icing things.
- (laughs) Okay.
- Oh no.
- Uh oh.
- [Guest judge] Not quite.
- Are you sure?
- Oh no Heather.
- Try a little bit more.
- Uh oh.
- Maybe some more icing.
- The cake is still warm.
The cake is still warm!
- Alright Will.
Let's see your recreation
of a barbecue cake.
- [Will] Nailed it.
♪ If it don't feel right then it's wrong ♪
- [Nicole] This is wild.
- This wild cake
is the result of two solid hours
of blood sweat and tears.
- [Jacques] And the spatula looks real!
- It's great cause the spatula's so real.
- So, I didn't want to leave anything out.
I didn't have enough time
to make a spatula but,
I had a spatula on hand so I
just went with the pre-made.
You can't eat it though, sorry.
- Oh my god this cake is incredible.
I love it so much.
Please, I love it so much.
If someone made this into
a hat, I would wear it.
- Nailed it.
- Alright.
I know you had trouble,
put his head back on.
- [Competitor] So, I mean--
- Can you say nailed it again?
- Nailed it!
(laughing)
- [Nicole] Oh Evelyn.
I like the straw arms!
(cake squishes)
- Oh no!
- [Competitor] Nailed it.
- [Nicole] I love this so much.
What a treat, he's like
(imitates croaking)
- Where is the top of his mouth?
I see the bottom.
- Yeah, so this is the bottom.
Here is the top.
- How can he chew?
- He's got an underbite.
- Oh okay I understand.
- He needs braces.
- Nailed it!
- [Judges] Whoa!
- [Jacques] It's moving!
- No!
Christian, this is my
favorite thing I've ever seen!
- It's all kind of abstract art.
- I don't mean to laugh but her lips.
- I had like two seconds
so I had to improvise.
- The gold that's just
slapped on her face.
- [Competitor] Nailed it!
(suspenseful music)
- [Jay] Wow.
- [Nicole] Oh you're dancing, okay, wow.
- You would dance too if you nailed it.
- You're right I would.
That is so, (mumbling)
it's good, there we go.
I got there, it's good.
The hair is great.
- He's got the flyaway like real life.
- Mhm.
What is going on with
the red around his eyes?
- [Jacques] One eye,
actually, is looking at me.
One eye is looking at Jay.
- Your Trump looks like the stress has
really gotten to him.
- I gave you guys the real deal.
(drum roll)
- [Competitor] Nailed it.
- [Nicole] Speechless, floored.
- I love the horn, but
what happened to the cake?
- I felt good and confident,
and then it was like a roller coaster.
It just went, I'm all right,
I'm cool and then I don't know.
Everything else was a blur.
- [Competitor] Nailed it!
- Oh boy.
I like him.
He looks like he's pondering his mortality
as he sinks into a bed of leaves.
- [Guest Judge] Oh look at his hand!
- Got some serious claws going on.
- Looks like some
osteoporosis or something
in the hand.
- [Competitor] Nailed it!
- Wow.
- [Guest Judge] Wow, wow, wow.
- Your cake has made me make a noise
I've never made before.
I love these eyebrows.
Oh my goodness, I love his taco hat.
I love that he doesn't have no eyes,
doesn't have no nose.
- One particular thing, I love
the little gold dots coming down.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Guest Judge] That's
kind of really cool.
- [Nicole] Jacques, what do you think?
- So, I think that Napoleon
looks like that now.
- [Competitor] Nailed it.
- Okay.
Your house is just, it's one level.
It's like a bachelor pad cabana kind of.
- I tried to do, um, siding and then uh,
the elf right here.
- It seems that your yard is like
a little haphazard.
- Nailed it!
- [Jacques] Uh oh.
That one is scary, Nicole.
- [Nicole] I think it
looks like a Pac-Man shark.
(drum roll)
- Nailed it!
- [Nicole] There's a
lot of things going on
on the cake, like it's a very busy cake.
Okay let's see this baby blow.
Activate your cake!
Ooh.
- [Jacques] Wow, this is an eruption.
(drum roll)
- Oh!
- Nailed it.
- [Guest Judge] Okay, okay.
- [Nicole] Oh no!
- Sadly, baking the
cake in the first place
was where I started screwing things up.
But, I just kind of stuck with it
and kept just trying to add
as many of the details as I could.
- This cake has a lot of personality.
- [Nicole] I like your tablecloth.
I think underneath the tablecloth,
the table is a little mushy.
It's like a fat woman in a mumu, you know.